Freak bitches made a point to be a fucking mute.
Right.
And I actually like pull it off and I was like,
wow,
like this shit is real,
you know,
and,
and the time that I really saw it as a.
sorry,
let me,
it was,
I mean,
I was in Canada.
Is before the no talking thing.
I was at some restaurant and Ron Perlman's manager came over to me and the actor
for that.
Yeah,
Hellboy in hell.
So that's a real shit,
you know,
he's a real dude.
Yeah.
So He'd come over and he's telling me about this new movie that he wants to do
and there's like a,
um,
there's a dad and there's a song or grandfather's son and dad and they're all,
you know,
they're all in the military,
different wars.
And he was talking to me about maybe playing the son and uh,
and we're having,
you know,
and I was interested in it because I'd done a little bit of acting up until
then.
And so I was like,
you know,
kind of,
trying to,
you know,
check it out.
And so I remember it was like every 30 seconds or minutes somebody to come up
and ask you for a picture.
And after like the 20th person,
somebody came up and was like,
oh Ron,
like,
you know,
I love a picture with you and I'll never forget it.
I'll never forget for the rest of my life.
He stood up and he goes,
oh,
you want a picture of me?
Like,
who the fuck am I?
You sure you don't want a picture of this guy?
And he was kidding.
But I was just like,
I was like,
wow,
like this is so fucking crazy.
Now here's a guy that's like a super successful actor.
He's been in like,
you know,
big TV series and like,
all these people are asking you to take a picture with me.
And I was just like,
wow,
like,
this is so fucked,
like.
But it was real.
I was just like,
wow,
this is like a real thing.
This isn't just like,
you know,
numbers on the Internet.
This is like I'm in a foreign country and I got all these fucking people coming
up,
you know,
like I was.
I was kind like,
I was dumbfounded.
You got a card on you?
What are you just going to pull out his Goddamn Mongo card?
I don't believe this.
When he got in there,
it's got a wallet.
He's going to pull out a Mongo card.
Let's see.
Right next to his Disneyland Year Pass.
Oh,
let me see here.
I've got to Disneyland.
I paragraph to find it.
No,
cause I tuck it away.
So I actually,
you have a Mongo card?
I would think that you would need a tattoo.
I would say.
Listen Bitch,
if you really want to be down for life,
we're going to get you a tattoo.
I already have a tattoo of the Mongols.
No.
What is it?
Like a UDP tattoos?
I have the try the Budweiser Trident and
you'll try and find your Mongo card.
How many of those cards you actually mine.
Look at that and there's the card from Geo.
The Hollywood pres gave me his last time I saw on Bam motherfuckers legit,
too legit to quit.
That's hilarious.
That is hilarious.
And My name was.
I Dunno.
What was your name?
Find it on there.
You never go by your real name?
Superman.
Super.
Why'd they call you sue?
Superman.
Because I was in such a physical specimen that when I was prospecting they make
you do pushups and stuff and I liked it.
Oh,
so this is back in the Jesse before the Jesse,
the body Ventura.
This is back when I was transitioning out of the seals into civilian life and in
fact if there's a good transition I can tell you about that shows how a book
should do due diligence before they write something.
There was a book written by William Queen and atf agent who infiltrated the
Mongols.
It's called under an alone and he infiltrated them and put like 25 of them in
prison.
Well,
in the book they wrote that I was a former Mongol governor,
Jesse Ventura,
blah blah blah,
blah,
blah.
Right,
right.
You know what they did before the book was published?
They sent me an entire copy of the book.
They said,
governor,
please read this and if you have any problems,
call us.
So I read the book.
I didn't hide from the fact that I was in the Mongols.
I never do,
but I did want them to change something and they did.
When I called them,
I said,
you stated the history of the Mongols that we started off like all white
supremist outlaw motorcycle clubs.
I said,
I would never joined anything that was white supremacy.
I said to me,
a biker is a lifestyle and the color of your skin has nothing to do with it.
And I said,
and the Mongols were not white supremacy.
And she said to me,
well,
governor,
how can you prove that?
I started laughing.
I said,
I think I can prove it easily.
She goes,
tell me this.
They editor at random house.
I said,
at what time did Mexicans become white supremacists?
Because I said the Mongols are 75 percent Latino,
Mexican.
I was one of the few white guys who could ride into east la and never be
bothered because of my patch.
Uh,
so how can you call us what the Mongols started because they weren't.
Mexicans weren't allowed in the hell's angels.
See,
I sold it.
So the Mongols were the Mexican bikers started their own bike club because they
weren't allowed to be angels
and these pigeons are eating from the top of it and they're so stupid that they
just get sucked into the grave,
Jesus and chopped up into that bread.
So like if you've had bread in Russia lately,
a lot of his page and page share this video to down.
Oh my God.
Three down to
one of them falls and lands in and just get sucked in at.
This is this,
this is fucking insane.
It's one of the most disturbing.
Jamie immediately make a video of this.
Send it to my phone so I can instagram this.
The world needs to know more.
Yeah,
it's a fuck.
That's harsh.
It's very gross and scary and sad.
How it's just a harsh life.
A dumber to.
Well look,
I'll where their heads are mad if your head was that little.
Yeah,
I guess,
but
yeah,
so I mean Zika babies grow up to be pretty smart.
Nope,
we haven't had any.
That's true.
Actually it hasn't grown up are really.
I don't think so.
I mean,
not that I've ever heard of.
I just made that up.
I think there's actually adult Zika babies.
I think so because I was thinking about making Zika hats for Zika people,
so it makes it look like their heads are bigger.
My Dad grew up in the jungle.
What jungle in India.
Oh Jesus.
So literally when he hunted tigers leopards a wild boar.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Your Dad did that data a lot,
man.
It was born in 1925,
so you know,
back then it was,
it's not like he would hunt them for fun,
but yeah,
it was a big game hunter.
Wow.
We have a tiger skin with a head.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
This last one that he shot was in the sixties when it was already.
It was already banned.
You weren't allowed to shoot tigers in.
But the,
uh,
this man eater went to a village and was killing people in the village.
So they had asked my dad to,
can you go get this,
can you go,
we know your family is a bunch of hunters,
can you go get this tiger for us?
And he's like,
well,
what's in it for me?
And they were like,
we'll give you $15.
Like that was a lot like it.
It was equivalent to that.
Somebody's saying to you today,
I'll give you $15.
Wow.
And uh,
he said,
well,
how about you keep your money?
I get to keep the skin.
So they made like an exemption and they were like,
yeah,
because he's getting a manometer.
It wasn't like he was just randomly coming.
Tiger boy,
that's a monster
here.
I'll tell you exactly how he did it.
I remember the story.
Clearly he would.
He got,
he went to where there was two trees side by side.
So he built up a little fort in this one tree and then he tied a bull,
a blu walks around the other tree,
and then he went and sat up in the tree at around five,
6:00 in the evening and he sat there and I'm reading magazines and stuff.
And uh,
and then he knew when the night falls that the tiger would come out.
And then as soon as the bullets started going crazy and running around the tree
a lot because he knew he was scared.
My Dad was,
he had the shotgun with them,
a three or a three.
Oh wait,
I think.
And uh,
and he had his flashlight and the minute his flashlight touched the barrel of
the gun,
it made a metal noise.
And then as soon as he did that,
the tiger looked up at him and instead of going for the ox,
leaped straight at my dad and the tree.
Oh my God.
My Dad just fumbled and shot and hit him right here in the throat.
Flipped back.
And then he,
he flashed the flashlight on his eyes to see if they were so glossy and then he
put another shot and just for safety.
And we have that skin to the holy shit.
You're done with gangster.